a former mi6 officer has told sky news
that some of russia's leaders believe
they're at war with the uk and they
interfered with the brexit and scottish
referendum campaigns
in his first british tv interview
christopher steele the former spy behind
a controversial dossier alleging
collusion between the trump campaign and
russia says there's growing russian
hostility to britain he's concerned the
threat isn't being taken seriously
enough this exclusive report from our
security and defense editor debra haynes
he's the former british spy who accused
donald trump of colluding with russia
now christopher steele is breaking cover
with a warning about the threat he
thinks moscow poses to the uk and europe
i mean there are
serious people at the top of russia
who regard themselves at war with us
and
the fact that our politicians neither
want to recognize or deal with that
is a big problem did you ever uncover
any evidence of hostile russian
operations against the uk
yes
everything from um corrupt leadership
money being brought onshore and invested
in strategic industries and the like
which is something of concern
two
potential attempts to fund parts of the
the brexit campaign
and interference in that
scottish referendum
some evidence of interference in in that
as well and what sort of evidence i
don't have it to hand but clearly some
of the same playbook that we saw so
money being moved through deniable
channels and coming out the other end
technically legal
there was a whole load of loopholes it
was steele's work on another historic
vote that made global headlines
in his first british tv interview the
former mi6 officer defended his
unverified dossier that accused russia
and the trump campaign of collusion in
the 2016 u.s election how much of this
is real do you think
i think the vast majority of it's real
what can you say about the credibility
of your sources
we were pretty confident that the
majority of the sources were highly
reliable
and others were certainly moderately to
highly reliable trump has said it's all
false
the uk's previous national security
adviser said ministers are alive to the
russia threat
every senior politician i've dealt with
labour conservative lib dem whatever
takes any threat of this kind really
seriously they take national security
seriously they worry about the impact on
the democratic process their right to do
so after his dossier became public
steele claimed he may even have been
targeted by russian agents while on
holiday with his wife
curiously it was
in my wife's sponge bag
two wedding rings one male 1 female
which were planted in her sponge bag in
our bathroom in our
luxury high security hotel in the
caribbean and what do you think the
message was we know where you are we can
get to you don't think you're
able to hide from us he's not trying to
hide but he hopes his warnings on russia
will be heeded
debra haynes sky news
and you can see a longer version of
deborah's special report featuring
christopher steele at 9 30 on sky news
breakfast and throughout the day here on
sky news
alec baldwin was handed a loaded weapon
by an assistant director who said it was
safe to use by calling out cold gun
moments before the actor killed a
cinematographer on his film set
court documents show the assistant
director didn't know the prop gun was
loaded with live rounds baldwin says
he's cooperating with police as they
investigate exactly what happened
sky's u.s correspondent greg milam has
this report from los angeles which does
contain some flash photography
they are chilling details of what
happened in those critical moments at
the bonanza creek ranch when a hollywood
shootout turned into a deadly real-life
tragedy
dressed in full costume as in this
picture he posted before the incident
court documents have revealed alec
baldwin was handed a loaded weapon by a
crew member
cold gun they'd called indicating they
were unaware it contained live rounds
a single shot to the chest killed
cinematographer helena hutchins and
wounded director joel
the investigation into that shooting
continues baldwin photographed looking
distraught shortly after the incident
says he's heartbroken
in a statement the actor said there are
no words to convey my shock and sadness
regarding the tragic accident that took
the life of helena hutchins a wife
mother and deeply admired colleague of
ours i'm fully cooperating with the
police investigation to address how this
tragedy occurred
and i'm in touch with her husband
offering my support to him and his
family my heart is broken for her
husband their son and all who knew and
loved helena
two days ago she posted this video the
perks of filming a westin she'd said
riding on your days off born in ukraine
and raised on a soviet base in the
arctic she was named a rising star of
the movie business her loss is
devastating to friends
she has this uh i mean tremendous talent
is given but
her human connection was incredible and
i think in the film industry which is
extremely competitive this is where it's
really important to have this human
connection it's been reported that
before the incident several crew members
had walked off the set over safety
concerns including misfires of a prop
gun the movie's producers say they
weren't made aware of any official
complaints concerning weapon or prop
safety but would review procedures
safety they said was their top priority
alec baldwin was a co-producer of the
film as well as its star
i can't even imagine what alec baldwin
is going to you go to work
you're an actor you're pretending to
play someone who fires a gun
um and then all of a sudden real life
kicks in and you have fired a gun that
has fatally injured your cinematographer
and injured your director
last week a picture of the cast
receiving a safety briefing was posted
this incident is raising serious
questions in an industry that says
safety around firearms on set is number
one on its list of priorities if that's
the case how could something like this
happen
that is the focus for investigators too
for many though it is the loss of a
woman described as always smiling always
hopeful a ray of light greg milam sky
news los angeles
in the last few hours helena hutchins
husband matt has tweeted helena inspired
us all with her passion and vision and
her legacy is too meaningful to
encapsulate in words our loss is
enormous and we ask that the media
please respect my family's privacy as we
process our grief we thank everyone for
sharing images and stories of her life
half term has begun for many children
across england and wales and scientists
are hoping the holiday could act as a
fire break for the large number of
infections in schools meanwhile the
focus is now on the booster campaign our
correspondent elena vasalinovic is here
now with the details school's out but
with cases rising in school-aged
children what are the hopes for this
break melina
well it's hoped that when kids mix a
little that can act as a break in
transmission because currently covered
rates among children have hit a record
high and when it comes to inoculating 12
to 15 year olds now that's been quite
sluggish the vaccines for that age group
have been available since the 20th of
september but only about one in five of
those children in england have been
inoculated so far now the rollout has
been happening through schools up to now
but since last night parents can
actually book an appointment and a
vaccination center and that is hoped it
could encourage take up because these
high case rates while with children
covet is thankfully mainly a mild
illness it does disrupt education it
also acts as a vector for transmission
into older age groups and that is
particularly concerning now with really
surging case rates across the country
and as we come into winter and there's
also been issues with a booster rollout
as well we've had data that shows that
fewer than half of all elderly care home
residents have got that third shot so
far even though they're eligible we've
also had complaints from some people
that they haven't got their invitation
for their booster yet but what the
government says is that if it's been
more than six months since your second
dose don't wait for an invitation just
book your booster and go get it done
thank
you well let's take a look at the latest
covered figures now more than 49 000 new
cases have been reported in the uk in
the last 24 hours another 180 people
have died taking the total number of
people who've died within 28 days of a
positive test to 139
326.
more than 48 000 people have received
their first dose of a covid vaccine and
over 26 000 have had their second dose
that brings the total number of people
who are now fully vaccinated to
45.5 million
let's speak now to dr simon clark a
microbiologist at the university of
reading dr clark thanks very much for
being with us how does this
break come at exactly the right time in
terms of cases
i think it probably has i i expect it to
give us some respite in terms of
in terms of numbers it will uh
remove an opportunity for spread that is
schools um but of course it'll only last
a week and and we'll see a drop in
numbers i think
and then i think it will probably start
to pick back up again as we move into
later autumn in the winter
if we look to scotland half term was
earlier there they peaked before us
their numbers are now
reducing much
lower than ours
but they are further ahead with the
vaccine out in teenagers aren't there
what lessons can we learn
well i think that the vaccine roll out
particularly with teenagers is a lesson
in infrastructure and organization and
it does seem that some of that
organization that works so well in
england isn't there at the moment and
that's what the government needs to
address
the same can be said of uh explaining to
people and putting out people how they
can go about getting their jobs i don't
think
that's there at the moment and hasn't
been with boosters either
we had a warning uh yesterday from
professor adam finn on the jcvi that the
the vaccines alone are not the magic
bullet but there is a reluctance
in government to
address plan b and the possibility of it
at this stage isn't there
there is and it seems a bit odd i mean
we're not seeing that with other
countries and while i'm not sure
international comparisons are terribly
useful um it does appear that the
government in this country and england
at least
are uh focused on the effects of covid
on the health service and while that's
important i think it sort of uh misses
what the effects that it can have on
other sectors of the economy we already
see that there are our supply chain
problems in england and
rest of the uk
i think if there were to be a mass
sickness and we did see it last year in
certain sectors particularly in food
processing then we could see those
problems that we've already got
exacerbated
can i ask you about this this delta plus
variant the mutation of the delta
variant potentially more transmissible
than delta how concerned are you
uh well i'm afraid i think this is only
heading in one direction to more and
more transmissible strains i remember 18
months ago people said it would become
more and more transmissible and less and
less pathogenic that means less or less
able to cause disease the first bits
happened but the second one hasn't
i think it will only get more
transmissible that's what evolution
really i think dictates should happen
but this particular variant we think
it's probably about 15 percent more
transmissible there's no indication of a
change in its ability to cause disease
though
and it is still at relatively low levels
in the uk at the moment but but if you
end up with a more transmissible variant
that places even more importance then on
the booster roll out doesn't it and and
really getting people's immunity up
it does yes it places greater strain the
more people you infect the bigger
problem you've got
and the boosters but also if we are to
move to certain
imposing certain restrictions uh they
will need to come in a bit sooner if
indeed it is more transmissible
and those kind of restrictions that
you're talking about being what
i think the government will move to face
mass will be or face covering sorry will
be one of the first things it does but
eventually it will have to bite bullet i
think and move to encouraging people to
work from home where they can and indeed
sage highlighted that yesterday
and what about the
moving of the the gap between
doses two and three the booster from six
months to five months could that help
and is that
feasible
it's feasible i don't really understand
the science or the philosophy behind
doing that i i think it's a case of
something must be done this is something
so let's do it let's do it but what it
does do of course is potentially reduce
the the the the time frame that you've
got effective vaccination here if we
were to have another wave in the spring
of next year
we don't know whether boosted immunity
or immunity is boosted after five months
will have started to wane before then
may do it may not
okay dr simon clark good to hear from
you thank you you're welcome
almost 7 billion pounds is expected to
be given to boost local transport
schemes in cities outside london the
chancellor rishi sunak is set to unveil
the new spending in wednesday's budget
as part of his leveling up agenda
a total of 6.9 billion pounds is
expected to be set aside for regions
across england to improve local
transport it includes london-style
improvements to bus services expanding
tram networks and upgrades to trains and
stations the government says it hopes it
will improve commutes and reduce journey
times
as part of the scheme the treasury says
greater manchester will receive just
over one billion pounds to improve
transport services
the west midlands is also set to receive
just over a billion pounds
west yorkshire will get
million pounds
and the liverpool city region 710
million pounds
south yorkshire teas valley and the west
of england will also get a cash
injection
but the mayor of greater manchester andy
burnham said as welcome as it is
infrastructure investment alone will not
make levelling up feel real to the
people of greater manchester that will
only happen when the frequency and
coverage of bus services are increased
and fares are lowered to london levels
other experts are also skeptical
what they're not announcing now is the
massive sting in the tail which is the
cancellation of the eastern leg of hs2
and a big scaling down of the project to
link up the northern cities
from liverpool and manchester through to
bradford and leeds and then newcastle in
the north of england
i think this scheme feels like something
that's been created in westminster for
westminster i think really the the
question is why are we getting this kind
of
funding around the edges and what we
really need is a london style system of
public control where it works for local
people and not just for profit
petrol prices are set to reach a new
record high within days according to new
analysis from experts the petrol
retailers association said they were
almost certain fuel price records will
be smashed before the end of next week
the aaa says prices are being
artificially inflated for profit
the u.s supreme court has allowed a
texas law that bans most abortions to
remain in effect but in a very unusual
move it's speeding up the process to
hear challenges to it
the law means most women have to travel
out of texas to get an abortion even in
cases of rape the arguments will be
heard on november the 1st
good morning it's just after half past 7
you're watching sky news breakfast
there's more evidence this morning about
the extent of modern slavery in the uk
the salvation army reports a huge
increase in the number of people rescued
from slavery after being forced to
commit crimes many say their families
were threatened and de brady reports
it's difficult to say that i was a slave
that sounds terrible to feels terrible
dan was threatened beaten and forced to
sell drugs for a man who turned him into
a modern day slave
the ordeal only ended when dan got
arrested and police figured out what had
been going on
in this interview filmed by the
salvation army he describes the abuse
meted out by the man who had initially
befriended him it was the threats of
violence towards my loved ones that
really
was the hardest
like when someone tells you that they're
going to beat your mother
that is
no man no woman ever wants to hear her
you just made me feel terrified
shocking as it is dan's case is all too
common a tale
2
662 survivors of modern slavery in
england and wales were referred to the
salvation army for help from july 2020
to june 2021
470 had been forced to commit crimes
such as growing or dealing drugs begging
and shoplifting that's up 62 percent
as a result of the pandemic we have seen
quite a significant increase in the
number of individuals being referred
into the national referral mechanism
which can be seen through either manners
of um county lines
forcing at people cocooing apartments in
order to
continue with cannabis growth
john renouff is one of hundreds of
salvation army volunteers who pick up
victims of modern slavery and drive them
to a safe house where they can get the
help they need
there are no stereotypes that you can't
say it's limited to one particular
nationality or one particular age group
we've moved people
of wide age ranges from 18 through to
their early 70s uh
that i think the number of nationalities
that uh have been helped is i think 70
or 80. the economic and mental health
impact of the pandemic may have made
more people vulnerable to the kind of
exploitation dan suffered as
circumstances change criminals adapt
their methods to keep making money no
matter how much misery they cause
ender brady sky news
let's return to our top story now and a
former mi6 officer has told sky news
that some of russia's leaders believe
they're at war with the uk and they
interfered with the brexit and scottish
referendum campaigns in his first
british tv interview christopher steele
the former spy behind a controversial
dossier alleging collusion between the
trump campaign and russia says there's
growing russian hostility to britain
i'm joined now by the director of the
russia and eurasia program at chatham
house james nixie good morning to you uh
mr nixie let's look at this central
claim to come out of the interview with
christopher steele that russian leaders
some russian leaders believe they are at
war with the uk is that how you would
describe relations between moscow and
london
that's entirely fair the reason is is
because we shouldn't be thinking of war
purely in military terms you think of if
you think of war in terms of economic
warfare cyber warfare diplomat and
diplomatic warfare as well that as the
russians themselves do then that does
entirely make sense so it's not as if
the russians are preparing for invasion
it's just that they see the undermining
of the uk can be done with different
more efficient also more likely to be
successful means than rolling over with
tanks which is clearly impossible so
when you look at the evidence say in the
financial sphere for example where quite
clearly there's a degree of
a clear degree of penetration into a
financial sector with money of dubious
russian origin which can be linked back
to people within putin's close or outer
circle then obviously there is a kind of
attack underway how you want to define
that precisely we want to define the war
or conflict or the the need to undermine
the need to to to reduce the uk's
influence at the exhibit with to
increase russia's influence at the
expense of the uk's doesn't really
matter the
reality is that the russians are are
trying
uh a number of different tactics from
their toolbox in order in order to in
order to make their own
foreign policy goals successful
and with then russian hostility growing
what if the government's response
christopher steele alleges that the
government's not taking it seriously
enough we've heard from former national
security adviser lord sedwell who says
every senior politician that i've dealt
with labour conservative libtem whatever
takes any kind of this threat like this
really seriously they take national
security seriously they worry about the
impact on the democratic process their
right to do so
who's right
is britain not taking it seriously
enough or is the threat being faced up
to
well i don't see the claims of mr said
will and and mr steele to be entirely
contradictory for what it's worth both
are saying that there is a threat to
national security here they may disagree
on some of the detail but i would
suggest that after the russia report
released
last year um then relative intellection
has been taken by the uk government on
that particularly again by may bring it
up again in the financial state so
whilst uh when there are specific more
visceral uh
attempts by russia to interfere in uk
society and in the democratic process
and i'm thinking of you know
radiological and chemical weapons
attacks and clearly there is a there is
a sort of a muscular response to that in
in some respects then with uh with a
financial undermining
um and the ability of russian oligarchs
uh those close to putin to
in-vehicle themselves into uk society
then that does clearly seem to be a case
which this this current party this
current government and actually many of
its predecessors if not most of its
predecessors
have failed to address
now christopher steele's also claimed
that the uk government didn't want to
face up to his dossier of claims about
president trump and about
alleged collusion with russia because he
said it would be punished by the u.s
theresa may at the time distancing the
government from christopher steele
saying he was no longer a former
intelligence uh officer working for
britain but but but what of that point
that britain didn't face up to those
claims because it was kind of scared of
the us's response i think there's a
great element of truth there if you
recall then when theresa may was home
secretary
she did not wish to escalate the dispute
after the levinenko case um uh actually
after sorry that's not correct after um
the initial invasion of the war in
ukraine and the annexation of crimea
because it was revealed in a document
which was
photographed with a long lens into going
into downing street but the uk did not
wish to damage trade and slash or
international relations with russia so
that does suggest that there is a fear
of retribution of some kind uh one might
ask what fear what that retribution
might be whether it's uh
expelling
uk businesses still active in russia or
uk personnel selector in russia as we've
actually seen from a bbc correspondent
who has had her visa removed so i think
it's right to worry about retribution
but it's not right to give into
blackmail and you've got to you've got
to reconcile those two slightly
contradictory facts
yeah and on that lord said will uh also
responded saying the british government
both theresa may and boris johnson have
said has to have a good relationship
with the president of the united states
whoever that is but because he meaning
christopher steele didn't see action of
the kind he was hoping to see doesn't
mean it wasn't taken seriously any
allegation of that kind of course is of
course investigated properly and
professionally just one final thought uh
from you james if i can what about
christopher steele's own credibility
many of the claims in his dossier on the
former president trump have failed to be
proven he himself has prepared said he's
prepared to accept not everything in the
dossier is a hundred percent accurate
how credible is he
well i think that's the important point
one doesn't have to agree with all the
detail to to
understand that the basic thrust is
correct there is a threat russia is uh
an actor which is looking to regain its
seat at the top of the table in the
world affairs and it can only do that it
sees it by said will himself sorry as
steele himself says uh uh with this sort
of zero zero sum approach so i have no
idea if some of these uh details uh
which uh he has not been able to prove
are correct and if he says to himself
and that that does put a doubt onto it
but i don't think that's the important
point the important point is is that the
uk has failed to take the threat uh by
russia seriously uh yeah in terms of his
actions its words its rhetoric is pretty
good it will call russia a threat it
will call russia a challenge it will say
it's uh the principal challenge even but
it's not able to to necessarily put that
into action when it comes to in
particular uh the economic challenge
posed by russia
okay uh james nixie thank you now these
claims were made uh in an exclusive uk
interview with uh debra haynes speaking
to uh christopher steele we have put
those claims uh to the russian president
vladimir putin and a spokesman for him
has declined to comment on any of the
allegations you can see
that full exclusive report from debra
haynes coming up at 9 30 here on sky
news breakfast and throughout the day on
sky news time for the weather now
it is set to turn wetter and windier
through the weekend as frontal systems
move in off the atlantic it will be a
chilly start this morning with a frost
in the northeast fog patches in the
south and a few showers around western
coasts and hills atlantic coast of
ireland and the western isles will be
windier and cloudier with patchy rain
wet and windy weather will spread across
ireland northern ireland and western
scotland through the day the rest of
britain mostly fine
still to come on sky news breakfast we
will take an in-depth look at the papers
with the sunday mirror's political
editor nigel nelson and the writer and
academic mo lovett
[Music]
welcome back it is time to take a look
through saturday's papers now with us to
review them today are the sunday mirrors
political editor nigel nelson and the
writer and academic mo lovett hello
again to both of you nigel we're going
to look at the express
uh first and it has coverage of
yesterday's debate in the house of lords
on the assisted
dying bill with a particularly moving
intervention from
frank field who was too ill to attend
but but sent a letter tell us what
happened
yes well what uh frank revealed was that
he is himself terminally ill
and as a result has changed his mind
about assisted dying he's now in favor
of it um i was desperately sad to learn
learn this because i've known frank for
years and uh like him very much
um but as far as the bill goes i can
understand why opponents uh object to it
because it does it does have some flaws
and the principle one is the six month
window to determine
uh when an ill illness is is terminal
doctors often often get this wrong
and what disability campaigners are
worried about is that that could be
abused
so while i think it is a basic right for
people to be able to choose when they
should die especially if they're in
great pay
i think you have to get any legislation
absolutely right this bill won't pass
because the government are not giving it
time
but i do think further consideration
should be given to bringing in
some uh appropriate legislation which
satisfies both parties
we heard from the former prime minister
gordon brown who is against changes to
the laws on safety grounds protecting
the vulnerable also at the archbishop of
canterbury saying that it's it's not
safe
to change the law at this stage
what are your thoughts
well first of all can i just echo what
nigel said is very sad news about
frankfield and this i mean actually the
debate in the house of lords yesterday
was um was very nuanced it was very
sensible it was very sensitive and i i
think we still need more i mean one of
the things that worries me particularly
in the netherlands where assisted
suicide is legal is that um people who
are suffering from autism simple autism
have been put to death and in canada
again a country which uh has legalized
suicide next year if you're just
mentally ill uh you will be eligible uh
for assisted suicide so um so i think we
need much more debate on this and you
know
we can all have absolute compassion for
people who are in pain and suffering but
actually what it's not one of the main
reasons that people choose um to go down
this route actually being a burden um
and just feeling worthless to societies
much more so maybe we ought to look at
that maybe we ought to look at
palliative care and how we remind people
who are ill that they're still human
still very valued part of our life
and and do everything we can to support
them because i think we l we need to
live in a life-affirming society and i
worry that we're not at the moment and
this is a bad time to to push through
some legislation like this
uh mo
the daily mail at page six of the daily
mail a warning that we need to get
jabbed in order to have a christmas not
via zoom and this is coming from uh
kate bingham the former head of the
vaccine task force
yeah i mean the headline is um it is
very stick isn't it um you either get
your jab or you'll have to face
christmas on zoom and a lot of us had
quite a miserable christmas last year
and the the article itself is a little
more carrot um and it's an in-depth
interview with like you say damn kate
bingham and she reminds us all about how
fantastic the vaccine rollout was from
the clinical trials that have relied on
half a milli
in citizen until uh to bring through
have you lost me
to to get the rollout uh ready um and
350 million doses came on stream within
six months she reminds us of all those
cues of people around football stadiums
and cathedrals all dying to get their
their jabs and how successful that was
to margaret keith keegan keaton
90 years old being the first person to
get jab and unfortunately what's
happening with the booster shots is a
less pretty picture so
55 of over 80s have been jabbed uh 39 of
over 75 and only 29 of all 70s and i do
think that this is a problem where
demand i know my parents are all waiting
for their booster jab and they haven't
been offered it yet they're both in the
over 70 category um so there's certainly
a demand to get the boosters but um you
know i think the government needs to put
in plans to get this rolled out because
we do know with the delta variant being
more transmittable and um
with the vaccine waning the efficacy of
the vaccine waning after about six
months that we are going to need these
boosters going into winter so um yeah
the government needs to roll up its
sleeve and but i don't like this kind of
threat of christmas hanging over us i
don't think that motivates people to do
the right thing and go and get the
booster job
i at nigel saying scientists are telling
the pm it's time for britain's plan b
the prime minister though resisting it
at this stage
yes and and these are these are sage
scientists who whose advice he's meant
to be following
uh he always said he would follow the
science but he seems to be resisting
this
i might get a real pasting on twitter uh
for supporting the idea of bringing in
plan b now and more restrictions but the
reason for it is it seems to me
this is the best way of avoiding further
lockdowns um you've got to get real
about this and the the figures in the
figures in britain are 50 000 old people
are infected a day
that's the highest in western europe it
compares with 9 000 in germany
5 000 5 000 in france and 3 000 in italy
we're way ahead of everybody else
and some of those people whether
vaccinated or not will get very ill
a quarter of all critical care beds are
now filled by covered patients
and if this is not go not to get out of
hand we must get on top of it and that
is why plan b and more restrictions are
better to have now than another lockdown
over christmas i mean critics argue on
mars wearing that that's happening in
wales and the numbers are higher but but
look at scotland where there are tougher
restrictions and of course the cases are
coming down there so we will have to see
what happens after the half term break
of course um nigel we're going to have a
look in the mirror now it's a story that
you've picked out which is about
children's table manners now this is a
subject close to my own heart but
actually this story is making me feel
better about my children's manners
[Laughter]
yes i mean that the
yes the mirror is describing them as
neanderthal table manners and uh anyone
with teenage children will know that it
is a bit like returning to the stone age
um what this survey is showing is that
six and ten children are eating with
their hands and licking their plates in
a rather sort of neanderthal fashion
now the reason given for this is that
too many children now are watching so uh
watching um
their screens while they're eating
often disappearing to their bedrooms and
as a result they don't uh they don't see
their parents eating properly with
knives and falls
so i would rather think the answer to
this is a bit of discipline in the home
which means not to stop children eating
eating over their screens but at least
having one meal with parents yeah as we
speak i'm sure at least one of my
children is drinking the cereal milk
directly from the bowl
nigel and mo and i'm not there to stop
them thank you both very much indeed
more coming up in the next hour here on
sky news breakfast
[Music]